Today's episode is sponsored by Dashlane,
try Dashlane for free on your first device.
And when you decide you want to upgrade to premium,
use my code biographics to get a discount of 10% on
premium, more on them in a bit.
All the 12th.
April,
1961 Baikonur Cosmodrome in what is now cans done picked up a transmission
that changed human history. I can see the clouds.
I can see everything it's beautiful.
Spoken in a youthful Russian voice.
Those words came from a place no human had ever gone before sat
327 kilometers above the surface. All over the earth.
Yuri Gagarin had just become the first man to ever visit space outside
his window.
Our planet hung brilliance blue against the cold darkness of the universe.
Thanks to this one.
Russian pilot mankind would now have a whole new frontier to explore a
frontier. We're still trying to tame six decades later today.
The name Yuri Gagarin remains world famous up there,
right alongside the alarm strong in terms of amazing firsts,
but who really was this Soviet space, man.
And how did he come to be sitting in that capsule?
Born into a poor peasant family on the Eve of world war two Gagarin could have
easily never amounted to much, but thanks to the sheer force of his talent.
He wound up changing history in the video today biographics is stepping into its
Soyuz and aiming for the stars as we uncover the life of the very
first space. Man,
If you were picking a time and place in which to be born 1934
and pushy, no would probably be pretty far down your list.
That's because Koshino is a pole in the gin, Western Russia,
those sort of place where hens room,
the streets and living in a weathered wooden shack is practically a
luxury.
But it's also because Cascina at this particular point in time was undergoing a
painful decade in 1934,
the Soviet countryside was already in the throws of a Stalinist
agricultural shakeup that resulted in a whole ton of poverty and
famine. And just a few years,
it would be shaken up even harder when Nazi Germany invaded.
But we are getting ahead of ourselves for now.
Just know that when you're ready,
Gagarin was born in Kachina on March the ninth, 1934.
It wasn't into circumstances that screams he's going to be great.
The third of four children Gagarin was the son of a carpenter and the milkmaids
both of whom worked on a nearby collective farm.
This being Soviet or Russia,
VAT mens doing backbreaking work for a pittance while wallowing in poverty.
It's been suggested that the reason the garden never grew the 157 centimeters,
five foot two in old money, it was down to childhood malnutrition. You had to,
despite this unpromising star,
the boy URI seems to have been relatively content. One feature,
everyone who encountered him seems to remember is that he was always smiling,
a big open smile. That would one day when him friends across the globe,
but first the boy would have to survive a period in which there was very
little to smile about on the 22nd of June, 1941,
when Gagarin was only seven Nazi,
Germany launched a surprise invasion of the Soviet union for the first couple of
years of world war two, Hitler and Stalin had been allies. But now as pans,
the tanks rolled across the flat grasslands of Ukraine,
better reuse and Russia. All the hatred between the two came bubbling out.
When the German front lines reached casino,
the Nazis through the Gar and family out of their home,
forcing them to build a mud hot EMyth,
three meters square and live in your gardens.
Two oldest siblings were arrested and sent to slave labor camps in Poland when
Gagarin and his younger brother bars were caught trying to sabotage German
vehicles by sticking potatoes up that tailpipes and enraged soldier tried to
hang bar us from an Apple tree.
It was only when Gagarin's parents begs on their knees for their five-year-old
son's life that the Nazis relented, yes,
even amid the apocalyptic horrors of life on the Eastern front,
your still managed to find inspiration. One clear day,
a pair of German Messerschmitts engaged,
willing to Soviet yaks and a dog fight high above the casino.
One Nazi plane was destroyed in the fight while one of the yaks was shut down
bugs. The rest of the villages.
Seven-year-old Gagarin rushed to help the down Soviet Hammond.
But when he reached him, the boy couldn't move.
Couldn't do anything but stare at this impossible, man,
who'd fallen out of the sky.
It said that this was the moment when Eureka Gar in first decided to become a
pilot. Finally in 1945,
Germany was defeated and peace was declared in Europe in the aftermath of the
Nazi occupation.
Garden's dad decided to move the entire household to the town of [inaudible].
It was literal. Mr. Gagarin sought up the family's wooden shack,
transported it bit by bit,
took his hat and rebuilt it by hand for them to live in.
It would be from this humble reconstructed shack on the fringes of this
anonymous town that Eureka Gar in which truly began his journey to the center.
Compared to the.
Deprivation of casino, because hot school is practically a paradise.
There was work for gardens parents,
a sizeable school where URI could make friends and meet girls.
There was also an aviation club.
The teenager joined where he learns all about aircraft disciplining to being too
young, to fly. Not that he yet seems like pilot material.
When Gagarin left school at 16, it wasn't to enroll in the air forces.
It was to train, to be a Foundry man, a decent enough in the USSR,
but not one that usually leads to a YouTube channel in the far future.
Doing videos about you Gagarin's who must have sensed that this was a dead
end after a single year in 1951,
he transferred away from his studies away from his family,
all the way down to the Bren's new technical school in Saratov.
Supposedly he was there to study tractors.
But where are you to ask the teenage Gagarin? Anything about them?
It have probably just given you one of his trademarks shy smiles that's because
Gagarin was really in Saratoga. For one reason,
the schools shiny new flight club,
unlike the aviation club in Kusatsu because the bigger one down in Saratov
really did allow it students to fly planes for the first time in his life.
Yuri Gagarin took to the skies on border yak. 18. Looking back later,
he would say that fluent fills me with pride and gave meaning to my whole
life. In 1955,
age 21 Gagarin enrolled in the pilot school and arm back the mid fifties,
a time of great change in the USSR.
Two years before Stalin had died in just one more year,
Nikita Khrushchev would make his secret speech.
Beginning of Thor that would see long lost freedoms regained.
Maybe it was the mood in the entire nation,
but Gagarin seems to have blossomed in R and Berg.
It was well upon at school that he met Valentina Gorev.
And so turns heads that she fell off of him without ever really knowing why it
was there to garenne took his first solo flight and MIG 15 jet an experience
that made even his Virgin flight in the yak. 18 appear trivial by 1957.
Gagarin was lucky in love and cruising through his studies.
He was recognized as a brilliant pilot, despite his short stature,
meaning that you have to sit at top of cushion to see out of the cockpit.
And this was perfect timing because 1957 was when mankind finally began looking
upward on August the 21st,
the world's first Intercontinental ballistic missile was launched in the USSR
designs, Boeing, the ultra secretive rocket genius,
Sergei Korolev the all seven SIM Yorker.
It was a breakthrough in weapons technology that left the USA eating Soviet
dust. But while Moscow loved the [inaudible] for its offensive capabilities,
Carla wanted to use it to expand mankind's horizons.
That's October another car that rockets blast it off from the bike and will
launchpad in what is now Kazakhstan, but rather than carrying a warhead,
it was carrying a small metal lobe. The size of a beach bowl,
venting Sputnik one became the first man-made satellite in orbit.
It was a moment that changed everything, marking the Dawn of the space age,
but Korolev wasn't done yet. He sent another goal one. So secrets,
so preposterous that only a handful of people knew about it.
Karlov wanted to send a man to space.
It was this impossible dream that would soon transform Yuri Gagarin's life.
Two years off to Sputnik's.
Launch in October of 1955 groups of mysterious recruiters began fanning out
across the USSR, looking for pilots by now,
Erica garenne was a leftenant in the Soviet air forces based in Chile,
Murmansk in the Arctic circle.
He ends Valentina had married three weeks off to Sputnik's launch and their
lives were now as good as that ever dream.
Then these mysterious recruiters came knocking a garden, his base,
and everything was just turned upside down alongside his comrades.
Gagarin was subjected to a battery of tests, physical and his mental.
There was so strenuous few could pass them. When those tests were done,
the successful pilots were sent to Bert Danco,
military hospital in Moscow where Gagarin Lacy recalled.
They tapped our bodies with hammers,
twisted us about on special devices and checks the vestibular organs in our
ears. They tested us from head to toe.
By the time the tests were over only 20 pilots remained 20 pilots from across
the USSR, the creme de LA creme of Soviet Hammond ship.
It was now clear to the remaining pilots. What all of this was about.
They weren't in the running to be the first ever cosmonaut shortly after passing
his medical Gagarin and Valentina left behind their cold,
comfortable lives and Murmansk and transferred to one of the most secretive
towns in Russia. Star city,
a closed down star city was a place of luxury unparalleled even in Moscow with
well-stocked shops and vast apartments.
But while life installs may have been luxurious,
it was also tough off as the first astronaut training program in the world.
America was still dicking about with chimpanzees at this stage star city's
trials pushed the 20 pilots to that limits.
They endeared G-forces even seasoned.
Pilots had never experienced underwent physical tests.
So rigorous that most dropped out.
Eventually only six remained all of them. Short men, apparently call-off off,
had gone and built a capsule. So small,
new average size man could dream of fitting inside.
I'd lost those six short men became to Yuri Gagarin and
gum and T 12. Gagarin was convinced that Tito would be the one chosen,
possibly the best pilot in the U S I saw he was intense,
athletic and educated in another time in another,
the place he likely would have gotten the job, but this one, the Soviet union,
the work is paradise. When word got to Nikita Khrushchev himself,
the son of peasants that the choice had come down,
do a poor boy from the sticks and a middle-class intellectual.
He supposedly told Korolev to forget teach off the first man.
And the space would be Yuri Gagarin.
By the time we had reached the two pilots that decamped to Baikonur Cosmodrome
on the vast planes of the Catholic step to prepare for the launch,
how exactly detailed took the news is a matter of some debate.
Although all accounts say he was outraged at the time, some claim,
he found peace with the snob in later life,
while others say he died still bitter at being robbed of his place in the
history books, either way on April the 12th, 1961,
it was good guardian who got out of bed, knowing he had a date with destiny.
Now, he might've been a bit nervous that morning, but you know what?
You don't have to be nervous about your passwords leaking out there on the
internet. If you use Dashlane, who is today's sponsor,
Dashlane is a one-stop shop for all of your digital identity protection
needs. If all your passwords are the same, that's a bad idea.
You can use dash password manage it's create insecurity,
store complex and unique passwords,
making it less likely that your accounts are going to get compromised with
Daschle.
And you didn't have to spend time resetting passwords or filling out tedious
forms and financial info. It does it for you with the click of a button.
They also have a VPN as part of their service,
meaning that you can browse the internet securely and confidently even on
public wifi. So make your life easier.
I had to dashlane.com forward slash biographics and try dash lane for free on
your first device. And when you decide, you want to upgrade to premium,
use my code biographics to get a discount of 10% on premium,
and let's get back to it.
If your idea of rocket launches comes via Hollywood,
you might be picturing Yuri Gagarin.
Saturn is capsule listening to a countdown before liftoff,
but that's image would be entirely wrong as Korolev thought.
The idea of a countdown absurd American nonsense.
Instead Gagarin said that listening to Russian love songs,
waiting for the final checks to finish that morning,
he had woken up at 5:30 AM to get to the launch pad.
Then he had made time for a quick pee against the back of his bus.
A bit of necessary business that every future cosmonaut would repeat in the
hopes of getting some of good gardens. Good luck.
Now a good garden was sabotage, but gigantic missiles pointed at the stars.
Not knowing whether death or destiny awaited him at exactly 9:06 AM.
Carla punched the ignition key. There was no warning,
just the sudden jolt of the rocket,
a roar of noise that seems to fill the universe.
And then Yuri Gagarin was blasting upwards,
leaving us behind in a way no human had ever done before.
Although he later claimed to have no memory of it. He was heard screaming,
informal Russian with that,
roughly translates as let's roll a little over 10 minutes later,
the story of humanity had begun its newest chap sat outside the window.
John's swath of bright blue impressed itself on the cosmonauts Ratan retinas.
It was the earth seen for the very first time by humanize,
as it really is a flattened disc flying through nor really
an orb in space, surrounded by endless darkness,
the radio crackles and car Love's voice came on. How are you feeling?
And so you're a Gar in replies with the first words ever said in space,
the flight continues well. The machine is functioning.
Normally reception excellence am carrying out observations of the earth
visibility. Good. I can see the clouds. I can see everything.
And then most poignantly it's beautiful.
What's it lacks in the poetry of one small step for a man,
one giant leap for mankind. It more than made up for, you know,
an estate as good guardian circled.
The se looked down on our welds as no one had seen it before today,
where you stay images of our planet,
taken from space blahzay about the idea that we can pull up a thousand photos of
the earth just by Googling, but try to imagine how urea garden,
the peasant boy from a poor Russian village, Mr. Feld,
try to grasp even the tiniest fragments of how the world
must've appeared to him to say it was likely or inspiring is
almost trite.
You'd probably need to invent whole new words to describe just how garenne
felt at that moment. 108 minutes after launch for stock,
one began it's returned to earth. It was,
he is good garden story almost ended though his capsule meant to
separate, but a cable refused to break. And now he plunged back to earth,
not as a streamlined dot,
but as a tumbling spinning burning bowl of metal in this out of control,
descent, Gagarin, almost lost consciousness, but through sheer luck,
the high temperatures melted the cable,
allowing him to regain control and then eject at the appointed moment at
10:55 AM a Russian peasant woman living on the endless grasslands outside
Gagarin's old student city of Saratov looked up in astonishment as a short
man in an orange suit, floated down toward the earth.
As this stranger landed right by her and removed his helmet and an attacker to
Rover managed to stomach. Have you come from outer space?
Beaming has great wide smile. Yuri Gagarin noted triumphantly.
Yes, he replied what'd you believe it? I said, I certainly have.
The Americans were informed first. They had to be,
nobody wanted Gagarin to be mistaken for a missile into successful flight
accidentally trigger world war three,
but the Soviets made sure it wasn't just Washington. The got the news,
even as good guardian was watching the thrum far up in Vostok. One,
his astounded relatives back home was staring at the sky praying for his safe
return. When it was confirmed, the spacemen had survived. His landing.
The weld went nuts in Moscow crowds poured into the street,
abandoning factories,
offices and schools across the other cities of the Soviet union and across the
Warsaw pact nations.
Then across the non-aligned States and even in the West,
people came together to celebrate this historic event,
perhaps the country where news of Gagarin's flight was received.
Kodaly was the USA.
When NASA's press office was phoned at 4:30 AM by journalists,
Sally spokesman yelled into the phone. What is this? We're all asleep down here.
The headline, the next day, Soviets put man in space.
Spokesman says us asleep within days.
Yuri Gagarin was thrown a lavish parade in Moscow where he was personally
greeted by Nikita Khrushchev often than us. It was onto a world tour and life.
As a living icon, Moscow sent Gagarin all over.
He visited Soviet airlines like Czechoslovakia, Bulgaria, Cuba, and Hungary,
but also capitalist States like Canada, Iceland and great Britain,
but he never made it to America.
Although Gagarin expressed a desire to visit JFK,
banned him from entering the country, but have a sore loser.
It seems the political era,
his plan was to turn the garden into a piece of propaganda or a demonstration of
Soviet superiority,
but their plan quickly hit a fatal bump the garden.
It was just too nice.
Although he was a supporter of the system he lived in Gagarin was mostly
apolitical. It wasn't the kind of going to make speeches,
extolling the value of Soviet tractors or what have you. No,
he was far more likely to just give that wide boyish smile of his crack,
a few jokes and win the hearts of everyone around him in this man.
Who'd seen the stars. Humankind came to see a universal symbol.
Someone who brought them together,
even in the depths of the cold war for Gar in though life as an icon
was pretty hot faced with a parade of celebrations,
honoring him across the planets. He had orbited.
He turned to drink before his flight Gagarin had been borderline Tito, her soul,
not wanting to mess with his flying after landing. He spent half a year,
more or less permanently drunk.
It was a mental state that would cause him to make a dangerous mistake in
September, 1961,
Gagarin was in Crimea for yet more celebration parties sozzled and out of his
mind,
he followed a gorgeous young blondes named Anna back to a hotel room on the
second floor when Valentina burst and the spaceman trying to escape by leaping
out of the nearest window,
only for his foot to catch and send him plunging headlong to us,
the cracked concrete impacted sickeningly against Gagarin's forehead,
leaving him permanently Scott. When he came to the hospital,
his brain was so scrambled. He initially thought I'd never fly again,
but no, the gods were for now still smiling on the form of farm boy,
not long after this Gagarin abandoned his new life as a global celebrity and
returned to working on the Soviet space program. This world of parties,
it wasn't for him. He was still less than 30.
He has infinitely more missions left to fly, infinitely,
more rockets to pilot didn't he.
[Inaudible].
If Eureka gardens early life was the good side of the Soviet dream plucking a
talented peasant, a farm boy from obscurity and taking them to the stores.
The last of his life showed it's nightmarish side in early
1967,
the new Soviet leader land Brezhnev made it known that he wanted something
spectacular to Mark. 50 years of communism,
the idea was to send up to Sonia's rockets a couple of days apart,
symbolizing Soviet supremacy. First Gagarin was excited.
He pulled some strings and got himself selected as backup pilots, just in cases,
fellow cosmonaut flatten their collar off fat,
Lil butts as the date approach that excitement turns to yeah,
a technical team identifying 203 faults that needed urgent attention garner and
helped them prepare a 10 page report for the leadership at Baikonur to send to
Moscow butts. When the report was finished,
he discovered something truly terrifying.
Everyone was too scared to send it with Brezhnev and charge.
The Soviet system had returned to its crudest ways shooting the messenger was
now practically a sport and no one wanted to be the bearer of bad news.
As the launch date approached Gagarin seems to have realized that getting in the
rocket would be a death sentence.
He begged a KGB friends of his to take the negative report to his superiors.
The friends had lost, agreed, and went to upper command, but he disappeared.
He ends everyone.
Who'd seen the reports will summarily fight or sent to work and humiliating
postings. And they are send of Siberia with rev.
In-charge rocking the boat simply meant that you drowned on the day of the
launch.
Gagarin accompanied calmer off to the rocket pack that Gagarin had a moment of
heroism. It kicked up a massive stink demanding.
He'd be put in that rocket shouting that it was his right as Komaroff superior,
but no Commonwealth didn't fall for it. Instead.
He said goodbye to Gagarin and Clem,
but into his execution chamber Komarov his wife was in the control room and they
spent the minutes before launch saying goodbye over the radio away,
the cosmonaut wasn't coming back.
This unable to do anything to stop this horrific chain of events.
And so on April the 27th, 1967,
Yuri Gagarin was false to stand helpless on the ground.
As the soils carrying his friend failed in Midat reducing vitamin a Culver
off to Ash. The cosmonaut never got over what had happened that day.
The wide smile faded replaced by a more Rouse expression,
openness gateway to depression. Maybe it wouldn't have lasted.
Maybe Gagarin Sunnyside would have returned eventually,
but we'll never know on March the 27th, 1968, 11 months. Exactly.
After calmer offs crash, Gagarin jumped into big 15 for a routine flight.
96 kilometers Northeast of Moscow. He crashed at high speed.
The impact killed Gagarin instantly age, just 34.
The first space man was no more at the time.
There were endless conspiracy theories surrounding Gagarin's death, but in 2013,
formerly classified files were released showing that it was just another case of
Brezhnev era mismanagement.
That same day [inaudible] Jackson accidentally flown too low passing,
incredibly close to garden's mic.
The huge Ashcroft had rolled Gagarin's jet causing it to spin out of control.
Sealing his fate Yuri Gagarin's ashes were into it in the Kremlin will in
Moscow, on March the 30th, 1967,
following a huge Memorial parade shortly after his teenage hometown changed its
name from [inaudible] to Gagarin and his honor today over half a century,
since Gagarin's untimely death,
it can still be hard to fully wrap your head around his achievement while Neil
Armstrong's moonwalk is probably more famous than the West Gagarin's flight was
arguably more impressive. Prior to that spring day in 1961,
no human had ever done anything beyond the confines of our earth.
Every technological revolution, every great Explorer, every brilliant scientist,
all had been limited to this one pale spec and the cosmos,
and then came Eureka garden. The moments, the goals not reached Orbis,
a new horizon opens for humanity. The first man on the moon,
the space shuttle,
the ISS NASA and space X's plans to land a human on Mars.
China's goal of a moon base.
They all STEM from one journey undertaken by this one
hasn't boy from Russia.
The story of humanity's expansion into space may only just be beginning,
but when the history books, uh, finally written in 100, 1000,
even a million years, they will all agree on one thing.
It all started with Yuri Gagarin, the first man in space.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe also.
Please do check it off. Fantastic sponsor. Who makes these videos possible?
Dash lane, LinkedIn alive. Thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].